the deadly wildfires continue to rip
through California forcing more families
to evacuate including many celebs whose
homes have been lost in the blaze so
many people are affected Miley Cyrus
Gerard Butler Lady gaga and more stars
are now speaking out about how they've
been affected by the wildfires as the
death toll rises hell right now over 30
people are dead and nearly 230 people
are still missing
so sad and Kim Kardashian is one of many
stars who had to pick up her house pack
up and evacuate in Calabasas she got
emotional at the People's Choice Awards
it's been a really rough week in our
home in Calabasas Hidden Hills and our
neighbors and Thousand Oaks in Malibu
this is such an honor and we would like
to dedicate this win to all of the
firefighters the law enforcement and the
first responders we really truly
appreciate what you have done for all of
us so please let's continue to pray for
everyone's safety so the big
conversation is since these tragedies
are happening it's actually bringing
Hollywood together and a lot of people
who live in California in this time of
need of course with Kim Kardashian
packing up her home it makes us all
think about our own evacuation plans I
mean how how would you pack up your home
if you only had one hour to get it
together basics your family your dog
photos I mean what we do I would take
photos because those are priceless and
obviously my family like you said and we
saw that Miley Cyrus was also someone
who is experiencing the same thing she
actually lost her entire home and said
that she's completely devastated but she
has a positive perspective she tweeted
this I am one of the lucky ones my
animals and love of my life made it out
safely my house no longer stands but the
memories shared with family and friends
stand strong and Lady Gaga also had to
evacuate her Malibu mansion on Friday
and shared an emotional message on
social media she wrote I'm sitting here
with many of you wondering if my home
will burst into flames all we can do is
pray together and for each other oh my
god so devastating right now and another
person who's dealing with this
devastation Gerard Butler his Malibu
home is half gone and he shared
photo we're all affected we we had to
evacuate some of my kids and my family
are are in hotels with this safe you
know at least 25 people lost their lives
a lot of people hurting in my
neighborhood and Thousand Oaks of course
you know the shootings I know this feels
really sad you guys but I mean we do
have to come together when we're having
this kind of disaster and I'm really
happy to see that Hollywood is handling
it this way but we can't forget the
animals who've been displaced in the
damage someone who spoke about that was
Caitlyn cuoco yeah she's an equestrian
lover and she lives in Thousand Oaks and
she was using her platform for good and
helping because she said it's in her
blood my father's was a paramedic
fireman for 15 years so my heart goes
out to the firemen that are out there
and all the people that are on the
frontlines saving saving humans saving
animals it's it's breaking my heart do
all you can go to your local shelter
drop off food drop off supplies anything
any donations of course a lot of
conversation is happening across social
media Leonardo DiCaprio is someone that
said maybe the fires have worsened due
to climate change our president of
course had his own solution which I did
not agree what I felt it was very
insensitive since so many people are
suffering right now I agree I agree I
want somebody to lead our country who's
going to bring us together in these
times of tragedy and not split us apart
absolutely and we want to shout out the
firefighters who are putting their lives
on the line they've been such a huge
part in this but of course we want to
know how you're gonna play a part in
helping with disaster relief let's just
keep this conversation going on social
media I'm at Halle underscore Stephen
and I met Courtney underscore teza know
until next time we've got you covered
for your pop culture fix
you
[Music]